today we're looking at the dialogue
credo and this is different than the
apology although it's very closely
connected with right you notice there's
some narrative continuity what happened
in the apology then we talked about last
class Socrates what happened so it's
killing he doesn't get killed in that
one he's on his way though isn't it yeah
very very good yeah he cuz I'm trial he
makes a couple speeches they're not
they're not speeches that are good
actually going to get him off because he
kind of you know Pope said the people
that are that are charging him and they
sentence him to death now normally in
the ancient world you would be sentence
and then he'd be killed not long
afterwards there's a camp for Socrates
because there's a religious festival
point we don't have to look at the
details of that very much it had to do
if you've heard of Theseus and the
Minotaur it had to do with a religious
festival that was set that was set
around that and they sent a ship up and
after the ship came back then they can
execute people again so they're waiting
to execute him he's sitting in a Cell
he's got you know lots of free time yeah
it was it wasn't too bad for him he was
you know reading books and making
friends with the jailers and just sort
of going about his day the way normally
does people come and visit him and
creeper comes and credo has been coming
if you if you looked at the dialog a
couple times you realize credo has been
coming during each day at a certain time
of the day he's showing up early this
day and he's showing up early because
he's got a break out of jail plant so
that's that's where this this takes off
socrates could get away credo is rich
kratos a foreigner credo has bribed the
guards he's arranged for transportation
he's talked things over with people
he's actually got a cup here opposes a
couple different places you go to
Thessaly you could go here you've got
friends over here because Socrates did
in fact have a lot of friends so credo
is putting forth the real proposal for
him credo has done everything that needs
to be done for this why is he doing this
well you know when you read the apology
did you feel Socrates deserve to die no
did anyone feel he deserves done if you
look at the Forum in in iler you notice
that I started sort of a devil's
advocate kind of thing I've started some
threats why that guy Socrates deserves
to die and I invite you to respond to it
you know that can be class participation
for those who don't like to talk in
class too much or those who actually do
talk in class and enjoy you know
stirring things up that you can do that
as well but yeah most of you don't think
he deserves to die
credo didn't think he deserve to die
either a lot of people didn't think so
they considered it to be what they talk
about in this as an unjust verdict right
we have that in our society you're right
some people get statins to don't
actually deserve to get sentenced I
don't know what the actual proportions
are I can tell you that when I when I
worked in a prison and actually they
taught philosophy and religious studies
in a maximum-security prison and I got
to know some of the guys here as well
because I was teaching the same class as
you know over and over and over again
and they weren't going anywhere you know
they weren't transferring to other other
places other schools they were taking
classes with me and one other philosophy
professor and we talked about all sorts
of things including their cases and most
of the people in our prisons actually
are guilty of something
right but there are some cases if you
talk to prisoners you find out that
there's a lot fewer cases than they
often think of as you know pure
travesties of justice where a person is
innocent and doesn't deserve it at all
Socrates looks like he doesn't deserve
to die though I mean he made a case that
he was doing
good things in the city did any of you
find that that idea convincing that he
was doing something useful those are all
things that he was teaching you right do
you think that that served any purpose
in society to make people better or I
mean it was he really corrupting people
that was where they were gonna kill him
because they thought he was corrupting
the young there was the charges so the
core question that we're gonna look at
today the Socrates says ok let's think
about this is credos plan should he do
it we're gonna look at the arguments for
that we're going to look at some of the
the basic ideas underlying that before
that thought I want to talk about a few
interesting features of this text it is
connected to the apology right the
Euthyphro by the way that you're reading
for next class that's also connected in
time that's right before he goes in the
law court so he has one big discussion
then he goes in gives a speech then he
loses his case goes to jail and then the
day before he dies two days before he
dies he talks with credo then there's
another dialogue which we're not going
to read called the Phaedo which is his
last day the day that he dies which
concludes with him dying wait do you
guys see any sort of inconsistency with
what went on in the apology in this
dialogue Socrates is he going to leave
why not
yeah yeah yeah you're right about all
those the Simmons is the right thing the
just thing to do he doesn't want to be
inconsistent with himself and it would
also be breaking the laws now is this
consistent with the guy who said you can
put me to death if you want but I'm
never gonna stop doing philosophy some
people you know when they first read
this they say you know the apology this
guy was saying I'm gonna keep doing what
I'm doing
you're not gonna stop me in this one
he's saying I'm gonna go along with what
the state says so is there a
contradiction when he knows what he's
doing it's not illegal in the first
place they're saying that it is okay
that's a good point yeah so there isn't
a contradiction no danger himself okay
yeah that's something to keep in mind is
the apology yeah there's there are
Plato's scholars who think exactly along
the lines that that you've laid out that
Socrates thought he wasn't gonna get a
fair trial period so he did making sort
of what do they call that a bully pulpit
again even if he was using it as an
opportunity to to say what he wanted to
say one last time and get it through
maybe even stick it to them a little bit
you know we we do get there's another
thing that's on there we get to see
Socrates put to the test it's one thing
to say all sorts of things about
morality and justice and you know what's
right and wrong and how important it is
to stand up for what's true it's a whole
different thing when you put to the test
isn't how many of you ever experience
situations of temptation where some
moral stand that you were
taking you found it was difficult to
maintain you had to do something that
was painful
well this is really painful that he's
gonna die
so what he's dying for it better be
pretty valuable just being true to
yourself in some sense I don't know if
that's worth dying for being true to
yourself along the lines of something
that matters maybe that's that's worth
dying for
what's going on you brought up the laws
you notice that he he actually makes the
laws talk what do you think is going on
with that this is something that people
read the dialog event fascinated or
confused or entertained by them
why do you think he did that if you have
any views about it if you don't maybe
you do by the time we get get through
this I'll just let that question kind of
set another thing to think about that's
going to come up this this semester over
and over again is this question of what
do you actually owe to your society
especially if your society isn't perfect
it isn't doing things the way you know
what to be there's something that we
call civil disobedience if you guys
heard this term before I probably in
high school right who do you associate
it with yeah Gandhi yeah
Gandhi's a great example who did Gandhi
influenced that you would put it to work
here in the United States yeah Luther
King yeah anybody before Gandhi that you
can think of in America
gets tied in with this this kind of
trivia but henry david thoreau somebody
ever read him you had to read him in the
English Lit maybe or an English American
lip English and English class they all
talk about this idea of civil
disobedience and they end up taking a
different stance than Socrates does here
in the Credo Martin Luther King had had
followed Socrates lines and said well
the laws are the laws and I benefited by
them so I really don't have any right to
transparent transgress them then would
he have marched what all those other
peoples marched with them they took a
different stand or at least what appears
to be a different stand when I first
look at it right I mean Martin Luther
King also made a distinction between
just laws and not just laws just laws
you have to follow unjust laws it's
actually wrong to follow and then that's
a letter to letter from a Birmingham
jail which you've probably have read in
high school again
yeah no should read it it's it's
important to know to read but Martin
Luther King is not basing his stuff on
Socrates in the Credo basing it on other
philosophical types because Socrates is
taking a stance that says well you know
you owe something to society you love
something to the state you can you can
go out there and be a gadfly but if the
state decides it wants to crush the
gadfly and you should go along with that
so we won't look at that theme a little
bit more as well let's look now at the
actual text credo comes in and what does
he say you know first day back and forth
about you know I've been reading a Saab
and the boat is coming
sort of stuff but what they really get
to the meat of it
credo says hey I've got an escape plan
for you let's do it you know here's and
here's all the the ins and outs of it
Socrates says let's think about this
credo is is going to make some appeals
he's going to bring up some some good or
some values some things that are going
to be lost if Socrates doesn't leave so
what is what are the goods at stake here
obviously its life right loses life well
so what is this credo worried about yeah
yeah that's that's a good concern isn't
it Socrates has a responsibility to
educate kids you know and this is in a
Iron Age Society which did not have a
social welfare system where if you know
Socrates was in the free class of
citizens we have property but you could
very easily leave that class your kids
could become slaves if you're going into
debt or stuff like that if you didn't
have somebody strong guiding the house
bringing the kids on a ride who knows
what happened for kids it's not like the
state was gonna take charge or you know
social services
whatever they call it here in New York
would come in so that's a real concern
so there socrates allows himself to die
he's not going to be able to do that
what else what other values other
concerns that come we'll call that
reputation and he talks about something
that he's going to have to endure when
he loses his reputation to shame that's
a powerful motivator isn't it nobody
wants to be ashamed you can get a you
can get people to put up with a lot of
things that are painful or that hurt
their interests
if you don't chain them but if you do
shame them that sometimes hurts people
worse any other thing you don't think
about bullying for example this is sort
of a digression you have these cases
where these kids are bullied especially
through electronic media and then what
do they do
why does it become an issue they
complain the school says I don't do that
anymore that's not how it goes what do
they do that really gets everybody's
attention
yeah they choose death over Shane
because Shane is that strong of a social
motivator even in our day and night
they're not really actually like
Socrates out there maybe making up a
misguided decision but it's one that's
understandable isn't it
what else what are some other values
doesn't want to look like like a bad guy
who prefers money to his friends is
there anything else that he thinks is
going to be lost
you're getting a good list here what's
the first thing he says I'm gonna lose
it doesn't save my reputation I'm gonna
lose somebody that I can't replace a
great friend friendship it's hard to be
friends with a dead person you know yeah
why would you lose is good reputation if
you refuse to this favor credo is
worried about his own reputation so I
should probably this is credos loss this
is also triggers loss this is what's a
good question there's there is one thing
that's like that again you gather you're
not going to catch this the first time
you can read their taxes this is why we
have these things sessions while I talk
about you know reading with text
multiple times
credo says Socrates you're taking the
easy way out so it's not just credo
you know to be it's also soccer cyclist
you Socrates you're taking the easy way
out by letting them kill you it sounds a
little strange that way well what's his
reasoning you're not consistently
following the path that you've actually
laid out the path of goodness they've
got the virtue the path of courage you
know you should be courageous and leave
the city
take a chance kind of live in Thessaly
you know you should have left you
shouldn't let those those those enemies
of yours win if you do there's something
wrong with you Socrates
that's what credo is saying if you're
reading between the lines actually this
is kind of a digression to free though
we don't know this from this dialogue we
know this from another dialogue he's a
really emotional guy so you can just
picture credo there you know shaking and
expostulating with misaki's he has two
credo it has to be led away crying what
Socrates actually does die there's kind
of a mistaken attitude on credo sparks
Socrates is quite what's the mistake
that big what if you had to just
identify one thing that's wrong with
credo is reasoning one main thing that
ties it together
what if Socrates criticized
says you're you're thinking of the right
thing here
I'll give you a hand who should create a
be listening to we're thinking about how
they they would see yourself
well creeper doesn't mention no and then
Socrates himself in this one is Kent
humble he doesn't claim that he is he
himself knows let me change the question
who shouldn't he be listening to there's
a the search phrase in there who gets it
one who thinks that these things are all
really the cream does but he's getting
that from somebody or from some group of
people decided yet we would call it
society in the Credo that's called the
many sort of you know mass of people
that you just sort of pick and you know
they're not necessarily people who
thought things through as a matter of
fact they're probably going along with
whatever happens to be popular at the
time you know think about the Whig mobs
behave they you don't look at mobs from
wall guidance right the mobs do things I
think about the way or many people can
be persuaded by easy emotional appeals
and actually you know quite frankly most
people don't like to think very long and
hard about things these things right
here are values they are good but are
they the real good are they what's
what's truly valuable for somebody like
Socrates credo is too concerned about
what the many think and there's sort of
a common temptation that credo is
exemplifying i know i've fallen prey to
this temptation myself i suspect that
many
probably falling prey to it as well you
know what's right and what's wrong but
there's this tendency to say you know in
this case the rules don't apply in this
case I'm gonna look at other goods that
have to be served yeah you know across
the board it still applies for instance
what's you know shouldn't be mean to
people right but maybe there's times you
shouldn't be mean to people but let's
take a one that that is probably easy to
relate to you shouldn't lose your temper
and swear at people should we all agree
that you shouldn't do that does anybody
think that that's a good thing to do
that you ought to be doing that then
you're not living life fully if you're
not doing that there are some people who
think that you know you can tell because
the way they live their life when they
get me a dance we're a people a lot now
when do we get a dance where people
usually yeah exactly we if we hurt us
but we think that we actually had a
coming we we may get a little mad but we
don't get mad like when we think that
they they're doing something really
wrong to us and if it's not right for us
to get mad and swear at people it's not
right across the board but there's this
tendency to say well you know you did
something to me first so I get to do
this in this case and that's okay for me
credo is doing something like that it's
okay to break the laws if the laws don't
turn out the way you wanted to if the
verdict doesn't doesn't play out the way
you want then you know you should you
know resort to other things
what does it do to a society if you if
too many people start doing that let's
say with the legal system
too many people started saying all
except the court verdict provided it
goes from my way but if it doesn't I'm
gonna find some way to undermine that I
can get a society work like that no
rules have to be honored by by at least
most people or else things break down so
credo is a little bit you know mistaken
Socrates says we have to think about is
this the right thing to do and are we
going to look at what the many say no we
have to look at what somebody else would
say and he says we need to know whether
this is the right thing to do in this
situation
but also in other situations right who
is Socrates going to be persuaded by
it's not going to be persuaded by credo
or the many so I mean that he's just
stubborn I take my stand here and nobody
will will convince me otherwise
is that a rational way to behave no so
if it's not the many because they don't
really know what they're talking about
and they make all sorts of you know
goofy decisions and I believe all sorts
of things one day and that in all sorts
of other things the next day who should
he get his his verdict from who should
he look
that would be an interesting that he
doesn't in this case if he were to do
that then that would be sort of pushing
the problem upstairs to God right that
some people do do that Socrates is
notable in part for not doing that and
you might say that one of the ways to
divide philosophy apart from another
discipline called theology they don't
teach theology classes here do that
because it's a private school but it's
not a Catholic school with theology you
you look to God and then try to figure
out what God is actually saying and make
some sense of it we're gonna look at
that a little bit with the Euthyphro
next class but Socrates is doing he
thinks that the answer is within us if
you look close or within him within the
human mind he he wants to get his
information he wants to get his advice
from somebody who actually does know
somebody who actually is wise and notice
he's not claiming himself to be wise in
this his dialogue he's just claiming to
have certain principles that he he
thinks are right and unless somebody can
prove those principles the whole he's
gonna stick with them so who do we want
we want the person who knows about good
and evil and what should be done now
what I'd like you to do just for a
minute or so think to yourself about
some case in your life where you relied
on you had to make a decision about
something right and wrong you made the
wrong decision yeah the reason that you
did so is because you looked at what
everybody else thought about or the way
everybody else felt or how people might
look at you if you didn't make the
decision that you did and it seemed okay
at the time
but then you realize later it wasn't the
right thing to do maybe it had some bad
consequences or maybe you felt you know
remorse about it afterwards think about
that for a minute yeah a lot of this
stuff makes more sense when you apply it
within the context of your own life all
of you can relate to that right because
you all had an experience like that at
least one in your lifetime even it's
something that's trivial as picking on
some kid because all the other kids are
picking on that kid we're stealing it
you know stealing candy because your
peer group said we're going in to steal
candy today hang on what does it gets
for candy in second grade
I'm so nervous to do everything I was
hanging out with the third graders yeah
and you know to be cool and hang with
the third graders you had to do the
things that the third graders doing they
were in shoplifting at the time
shoplifting can worsen freeze a moment
yeah well things have changed since the
present kid I mean we live way out in
the country and we had this uh.this it
wasn't even ah what do we call it a
convenience store right and he had like
a candy aisle yeah one of the kids went
to the front and got a got a bought
something so he had a bag and then he
walked back my house and then we were
supposed to take the candy and like put
it in the bag and it was a fiasco
because you know what are we doing we're
dropping it in there's really no way is
he and like the the clerk is over there
looking at
and I you know are just thinking about
Oh God we're gonna get caught we're
gonna get caught you know my parents are
gonna kill me we didn't get caught and
you know the candy there's actually an
expression there's there's no food so
sweetest food that you've stolen it was
pretty sweet but you know think about it
you think about it later I was not the
right thing to do did did the fact that
my my older compete really everybody's
doing this
that make it a good thing to do no and I
could think of much for myself a lot of
big things a long way that I've done
where rather foolishly I listen to
people that I shouldn't have listened to
and then you you know reap the fruits
all of you can think of something like
that right in your life who could you
have gone to you know the Socrates
doesn't tell you in this dialogue who
actually does know he gives you some
characteristics of the person that that
would know we're going to talk about
that a moment like just will actually do
a little way no dialogue back and forth
about that I'm gonna get that but keep
this in the back of your head as we're
going through the restless who would
have known in the situation that you
found yourself what the right thing to
do was who would have given you the good
advice I'm going to skip over how the
many actually goes wrong what's really
key here in this this discussion about
whenever we find ourselves in a tough
situation like Socrates is then we have
to actually ask ourselves what is to be
done
it's that question that he asks in the
text because we don't always know that's
what we call practical reasoning the
part of philosophy that's called ethics
you guys are later on down the line I'm
going to take
higher-level ethics class when your
juniors and seniors hopefully you're
gonna learn some things about ethics
before you get to be juniors and seniors
so you can make some pretty technical
decisions on the way right dad is all
concerned with what what ought to be
done what should we be doing what
shouldn't we be doing in this case you
know that's a particular problem should
Socrates leave and break the rules of
the city Socrates says that a good life
is to be valued not just these things
not just life by itself but a good life
and there's a lot of different ways to
answer the question what is the good
life which is a question of ethics again
ethics is not just about right and wrong
what you should do and what you
shouldn't do it's also about what kind
of life you think is good for human
beings to live and I think all of you
want to be successful right you're all
planning to have careers that's part of
why you're in college that would be a
component to the good life for you but
it would that be the only thing you
require for the good life to the career
there are some people I talked about
this earlier today in my ethics class
who see the good life precisely in terms
of work and just work maybe somebody you
know
are they are they getting the whole
picture what goes wrong in those certain
cases okay I mean they're if they're
pursuing a real good a genuine good they
do it a little bit too much there's no
balance okay look that's a good place to
start there's no balance so if we've got
when you have a balance you have some
sort of thing in the middle and then you
have two sides work over here what's
what's on the other side there should be
there yeah mostly they all work and no
play makes Jack a dull boy you're next
yeah usually people who are what we call
workaholics their family lives suffer
they have higher rates of divorce their
kids you know later on so you weren't
ever there for me that's probably one of
the greatest damages that takes place
they also don't develop you know when we
play we develop other aspects of
ourselves and you know if you're
workaholic you also won't be enjoying
some some other Goods you won't be
developing yourself all of you know
people like that right they've made some
sort of mistake with respect to what the
good life is Socrates thinks that the
good life he says is a life that's just
and honorable that's what makes life
good for him fundamentally so if he has
to choose between being jealous and
educating his kids he's going to take
being just doing the right thing there
are plenty of people who would be
perfectly fine with doing the wrong
thing so long as it helps of kids right
again you probably know people who have
done that my mom would actually
she would she was very hard on us as
kids but she had no problem about lying
to people so long as that you know
opened up opportunities for us I thought
that was a little weird myself but you
know people Socrates thinks that if it
can't be a just life it's almost worse
than they're not living just an
honorable that's what he wants to be so
that's what's motivating him the other
thing is how does he finding how is he
finding all these things out there
reasoning and this is not something
that's talked about in the dialogue that
this is going to be a theme with us over
the semester when we use this word
reason we have a couple different
meanings for this right why are you here
you have a reason to be here because
you're taking a class for credit so
that's one sense of the term reason but
you are also rational right you are a
human being and because you're a human
being you are a reasoning being you are
a rational being that's why you know we
we have classrooms and we talk about
these sorts of things dogs you know get
training the dogs teach each other in
classrooms give each other grades tell
each other how they ought to progress
the other you know reading this text or
something like that
no we do that B reason about things we
reason about things on all different
levels sometimes we do it poorly and
sometimes you do it well but that's part
of that's what makes us distinctively
human one of the definitions for human
being that came up brilliant philosophy
is the rational animal so Socrates
thinks that this is part of what makes
most human being rational following
reason not just following our heart or
desires but following reason what reason
tells us is the right thing to do and
he's going to follow it up here's where
it gets really interesting a reason
itself the rational life is a good thing
so you can put that into the balance you
know when you're doing practical
reasoning a lot of what you're doing is
weighing does this side way more well
than I should do this action does this
side way more than I should do this
action for Socrates one of the things
that's really heavy that's pushing down
the scale is being rational being
consistent sticking with what he had
said before now yes sort of a standard
filter' the wise man and what is the
wise man why it's about here's where I
want to introduce another theme that
you're gonna see come up throughout the
semester as well we call these moral
values and they're they're you know
instantiated they take certain forms we
can debate about them in fact do debate
about them the next dialogue that we're
going to read we're gonna see not only
do we debate about them we get angry at
each other about them what do we get
angry at each other about what do we
debate about when it comes to moral
things you could say abortion or
euthanasia right those are topics what
is the real general thing we don't ask
ourselves abortion yes or no we say is
abortion right or adjust
just or unjust right we can also ask the
whether things are good or yeah maybe
Justin and good might be the same thing
in some cases but maybe they're not in
some cases you know all of you are
healthy right I hope so
being healthy is good being sick is bad
it's not that you become a unjust person
by being unhealthy but it's not good for
you to be Socrates says that the the
person we want to look to the wise
person is somebody who knows about the
just and the unjust the good of the bad
and then uses some other terms can you
remember what those terms were uses kind
of formula and he says the just and the
unjust the good and the bad and he
changes or at least the translator
changes the terms that he uses yeah well
then the wise is the one who actually
knows about this and the unwise is the
one who has all mixed up about it or
think they think that they've got the
right thing but they're mixed you know
they've got a walk yeah see it
but we can change those two evils who
want to and that's good
the Greek terms are pretty malleable you
can make them fit things uses another
thing that we wouldn't normally think of
as moral but in terms of what we call
aesthetic how things appear to us uses
terms like this or the Oh everything on
this side is banned over the other side
it's good right he wasn't being fair in
the sense you know each person gets like
a candy bar and you don't you know take
anything more than as your do or
anything like that or everyone you know
follow the rules
he means Fair is in beautiful another
way of translating this is beautiful by
the way of translating it is noble or
thanks and another way that he does it
in this is honor or dishonor well how do
you think that that's important for
somebody to know about isn't that kind
of weird
I mean for somebody to be a good ethics
guide sure they ought to be able to tell
you what's right and wrong yeah I don't
know yeah I don't know it's what's good
and what's bad why should they know
things about you know like what's noble
and what's bass you know when you don't
use terms like that we talked about
people's be
like a decent person for you know
repugnant or stand-up guy or a punk we
have all sorts of terms for these sorts
of things those are more in this
category that in the category the just
or the unjust you know it's lying behind
this idea goodness is attractive and
evil is in some way discordant or ugly
and it might appear beautiful from this
side or noble from this side but then
you take a walk around it you see that
it's not with any of these things you
can distinguish between what's
apparently that and what's really that
and the person who knows who is wise
would know about all these sorts of
things how do you think they find out
about that well for Socrates it was -
reasoning not just listening to the
crowd not just accepting things were you
know on face value but actually thinking
about them that's how he got himself in
trouble going around looking for the
person who could meet these criteria so
when he was going around to all these
politicians isn't this the sort of stuff
that politicians ought to be
knowledgeable about what's really just
and unjust as they turned out not to be
so that's why they're getting so that's
that's why that's the kind of person
that he's looking for that person
doesn't show up on this dialog so you
have to ask yourself you know here's a
good place for us to actually sort of
pause think back to the mistake that you
made who should have listened to is
there somebody who
would have been knowledgeable or at
least more knowledgeable than where you
work at the time about what was just an
unjust was good or bad what was
honorable or dishonorable who could you
think of probably done that expresser
right flew into your life I know you
know I had I had some grandparents I
wouldn't go for something like that my
grandpa my dad side he would have been a
good guy to break long he did terrible
things and didn't you know none brand
about it now his wife his long-suffering
wife his second walk is that right -
actually she was a very good you know
boys I could go to her did you have
people like that in your life who do you
have now again you know most likely it's
not gonna be your ethics professor
prettier of a philosophy professor who
do you go to to find out you have to
figure out what's right and wrong cuz
you're not a genius that yeah my parents
yeah and if your parents actually truly
you know dunno Socrates would say
perfect
you found them somebody like this is a
solid gold yeah
even when you're a kid though you could
have just asked yourself well is there
anything you know that was wrong with
your doing so you didn't though I need
to ask anybody
yeah I need to do is think about it yeah
I mean you know Socrates seems to think
that something along those lines a deep
in their heart of hearts we actually you
know could figure it out but it's buried
under a lot of stuff there's one problem
with that too there are an inflated uh
something about this there are some
people that we read nowadays terms
sociopaths
sociopaths lack a sense of
that's why they're so dangerous and
that's why they don't respond to
treatment because they don't care
they're only interested in certain Goods
like power and pleasure things like that
they'll do anything that it takes to get
it we're gonna look at that a little bit
more when we look at Republic look one
that I'd like you to keep thinking about
that this is this notion of who should
you go to that that's you know there are
certain big ideas that when the semester
is over and actually when you've left
Maris I would really really like you to
carry with you I don't expect that
you're going to remember most of what we
actually cover in class because people
don't that's what you have your notes
for things like that there are certain
issues certain basic ideas that I really
like you to have as part of your toolkit
in these and one of those is this notion
of who should I place my trust in who
should I be getting my understanding of
moral values from because that's a
project that you each one of you as an
individual as a developing human being
that as one who's actually early in your
development all of you were around you
know 18 19 maybe this is something that
you should you know think very carefully
about because you don't want to be 40
years old and realizing that you made
the wrong decisions with this what else
that is important about this dialogue
Socrates
he brings up the laws right what are the
laws stadium
what is Socrates saying to himself and
to credo and putting in the mouth of the
Athenian laws they're pretty hard on the
birthday I mean he goes up the the
dialog like just the law saying Socrates
don't break us Socrates says screw you
I'm breaking you he didn't
the laws make arguments they give you
reasons why he should stay around and
obey what are those reasons can you
remember any of them yet yeah they
provided they not only educated reason
they provided a very framework in which
that could happen which his parents
could marry and he could be legitimate
that sounds like something that you know
you ought to pay somebody anything else
yeah
yeah you know in the ancient world the
laws compare themselves to mothers and
fathers in the ancient world things were
quite a bit different in the
relationship between children and
parents than the in our curve
most of us parents were month had a much
higher status compared to their their
children and there wasn't a lot of you
know democracy in the household or you
know what do you think a little Johnny
you know about this or that it was the
parents decided because they're the ones
who made you and some parents will
actually say I made you and I can unmake
you
you know things like that the water was
sort of like super parents they made the
parents so you know
Socrates yeah the water saying he's like
a slave what else there's something that
we brought up earlier they say what are
you doing are you going by any act of
yours to overturn us the laws in the
whole state do you imagine a state can
subsist and not be overthrown in which
the decisions of why have no power that
are set aside and overthrown by
individuals if Socrates does the wrong
thing in this case it is it has
repercussions for the society doesn't it
we just talked about this a little bit
could a society last if everyone says
well all looks at the laws so long as
you know turns out my favor as soon as
it doesn't I'm going to break can you
have a society like that can even play a
game like that you know let's say we're
playing what do you want to play
baseball football hockey anything will
sit just right did you ever play chess
with somebody who cheats it's very hard
to cheat at chess how would you do it
you'd have to break a rule enough just
like
well you know my pawn can actually move
like a queen there's not much of a game
with Jesus do that and you know you
won't feel the play sooner or later you
can't tell anything apart the laws also
say what was our agreement with you when
you entered into the courtroom
what were you agreeing were you to abide
by the sentence of the state if you
don't like the way things go in your
state
Socrates then why did you stick around
for 70 years if you think the laws are
bad laws why didn't you go off to Sparta
you keep talking and they say this
dialogue you keep saying that Sparta and
Crete have better laws than us
because Socrates and Plato were actually
sort of critics of democracy and Athens
was a democracy Sparta was depending on
how you want to see it and Oleg Archy or
an aristocracy not everybody gets a vote
not everybody has to hold office so you
know if Socrates didn't like it why
didn't he go somewhere else as a matter
of fact he liked it so much the laws say
that you never left the only time you
ever left was to go on military service
everybody else you know they go on
vacation somewhere you didn't you went
on vacation here what do they call it a
staycation right that's the new term for
when you take off work and you just sit
around the house watch TV or play games
you chips
and don't go into work so what do you
think the laws have a good case so they
have a good case for Socrates yes there
no yes why yeah it's a lot harder to
integrate these days used to be a lot
easier what else any of you have any of
you have other reasons for finding this
convincing or do you think that the laws
are wrong Socrates making the wrong
choice yeah what do you think all of you
have an opinion I know people when they
read this text they're you know
sometimes they're like yeah this is
great but sometimes like this is this is
absolute yes I can't believe that that
they don't they'd go along with this
fascist stuff go to extreme positions
let's put it a different way though so
if Socrates let's say Socrates does owe
this to the state what about you and the
society that we live who do you all
thanks to all of you have debts and I
don't just mean you know financially you
know do you guys have you guys have
loans a lot of you and if loans aren't
paying it then scholarships of some sort
or mom and dad and if it's mom and dad
come Thanksgiving if you're spouting
stuff at the dinner table
how American society is fascist or you
know is terrible or something like that
they'll they'll remind you who's paying
for your education you owe them
something and if you decide to not major
in business as you originally planned
and to major in art history it's done
you may get a call from mom or dad
saying I'm shelling out all this money
for your education you owe me so there's
there's that but who else to you old
things too
let's think about the fabric of society
all of you are healthy
all of you are relatively well-adjusted
I'm assuming you know you didn't go
through war or you know you weren't you
know the victim of crime crime for stuff
like that do you owe anybody for that
yeah country yeah the country as a whole
you know we just have this big 9/11 the
day the 10 year anniversary and the FBI
was on high alert
agents were called in for the entire
weekend working on double shifts and
stuff like that the people on the
bridges around here making sure funny
business going on with that police
presence was stepped up everywhere
it becomes much more visible they
actually put out some communique is
because they didn't want people to get
alarmed that some of the police would
actually have automatic weapons which
they did why do they have that to
protect us do we owe them anything
well it's their job well that's a good
point that's honorable but it's their
job yeah I and then when I comes to the
military I'm actually that myself and my
attitude when I hear people say you know
troops shouldn't be put in harm's way is
what do you think it signed up for you
know you take the money to take the oath
you you're probably gonna be put in
harm's way it's the same with police or
who else firefighters who else is on the
front lines you know keeping you safe
the organs of society of the coma and
about nurses and doctors nurses more
than doctors own nurses face you know
the chance of getting all sorts of
horrible diseases on a daily basis if
something comes running we don't think
of that as a huge risk like a
firefighter please do we owe them
anything what do you think it could just
be their job we owe them money we owe
them maybe we owe that you know we
respect our country provides all the
stuff what what do we owe well yeah then
that's what you eights depending on how
much you pay what you guys right now are
fortunate most of you I'm guessing in
that you're not you know making a lot of
money because you'll see the more money
to make the bigger the bike gets you
don't have to make very much because
you're middle class anymore so taxes
let's go let's say we do a little bit
broader that's providing support to the
country
there are laws about taxes
you have to follow the laws do you have
to follow all the other laws sure what
if you don't like the laws
what does the Credo pulled out as a
possibility the laws actually sing this
so you can't break us just because you
don't like us agreements oh here's your
pen okay what should you do if you don't
like the laws what do you have a duty to
do yeah you could try to you could try
to get into politics and change to
become one of the rulers the prietto's
the dialogue doesn't actually have the
laws saying yeah there's another way to
change laws though and that's to do